here on the medica border between poland
and ukraine former members of an elite
french military force are helping to
protect refugees who may be unaware that
war isn't the only thing they're fleeing
from this morning we we found three
three men that was trying to
to
get a bunch of women into a van i cannot
100 say that
they were trying to recruit them for sex
trafficking but when we started talking
to them when we approached them they got
nervous and they just left immediately
so
we just we're just here to help many
ukrainian refugees reaching border
countries seek to reunite with friends
or family members across europe we are
waiting for him after a five-day car
journey from the bomb city of chernahev
arena seeks shelter on the suret border
between romania and ukraine
she is waiting on a friend in berlin to
arrange housing for her and her two
children while her husband and parents
stay behind
help offered by strangers who greet her
and other refugees is abundant
but so are the risks
there are many
very dangerous propositions from
different people
they can offer
us help
for free
to reach
any country but it's not true
along this border town man offering free
rides to women have been sent away plane
clothed intelligence officers are on the
lookout for criminal activity and law
enforcement teams are advising women
arriving at the borders on how to stay
safe we try to discuss with every couple
for example coming from ukraine
especially women and young girls
to have
some preventive measures like to
have a full charge battery or to
remember every time the number of the
car
that
they were going in a recent report by
the european commission estimates the
annual global profit from human
trafficking is around 32 billion dollars
sexual exploitation is most common in
the 27 nation block with nearly
three-quarters of all victims female and
almost every fourth a child
and in humanitarian crises like these
those numbers go up the risk for these
things to happen is very high so
in times like this when people mobilize
but the risks for other people that can
capitalize on the pain of this
these families is very high
the challenge now once borders have been
crossed is to stay safe and alert until
they reach their destination
jillian wolf al jazeera